so i think that's where it becomes hard
paying full attention instead of paying
partial attention paying partial
attention is easy it just doesn't really
result in your best work or your most
efficiency or really being present with
the people you care about that you're
hanging out with
touch of wine welcome to the show
thank you chris it's good to be here
how did you arrive at thinking about
multitasking and mono tasking what's the
journey that's taken you to think about
that
yeah so a lot of it came out of my own
personal experience um
i'm a citizen of the world that we live
in which is super distracting to begin
with got all this technology constantly
asking for our attention
our smartphones computers other devices
uh and then on top of that i kind of
threw in some
personal challenges that were of the
next level distraction variety a few
years ago i went through cancer
non-hodgkin's lymphoma
also an entrepreneur got a business for
about 20 years called juniper books that
is very you know creatively
um
broad in what we do with books and very
you know demanding of a lot of my
attention and creativity and
productivity i'm also a parent of two
teenagers
and
you know i wanted to figure out a way to
navigate all the things i was going
through
figure it out for myself and and what i
figured out i thought i could share with
the world when i learned about
multitasking and mono tasking
what was the
genesis of that was there a point where
you were juggling so many things with
the family with the work with the health
was there a particular sort of period of
time in which everything kind of got a
bit much
yeah i got to the point basically
between
2016 and 2019
where i hit the wall i just
there was couldn't possibly have been
more that i was dealing with at one time
and i was finding it really hard to
switch back and forth between what i was
going through for my health for my
business for my family
and
you know i what i decided to do was kind
of look back at how i'd done it in the
past so i'm a pretty productive person
um
and i'm pretty creative and they're i'm
also very ambitious a lot of things i
want to do in life so i kind of look
back how have i done this before when
have i
not felt overwhelmed by it
and you know one
pattern that i recognized was that when
i gave my full attention to one thing at
a time
i got things done well people said you
know the work is great
and my kid said you know we had fun like
you get the feedback from the world
um that you're doing a good job and you
don't feel so overwhelmed
but then you know once i layered on all
these other distractions that i was
dealing with um it just felt like i
always had to be staying up late getting
up early depriving myself of rest
not
exercising and just taking on more and
more and more and i never felt like i
was caught up
so it's definitely in that three-year
period you know where i was like i gotta
find a better way
is there a tension between the amount of
work that you can get done and the
amount that you focus on single things
and the quality of work is there a way
that all of those are kind of
interlinked
yeah absolutely so so there's a bunch of
research that's been done on
multitasking and the research basically
shows that when we multitask so when we
take on more than one thing at a time
you usually have the cognitive variety
so like you're doing an email and trying
to listen in on a conversation whether
it's in zoom or or something else
we tend to make more mistakes
and things take longer
part of that is due to the fact that we
just can't multitask
what we call multitasking is actually
task switching
so we're going from one thing to another
we're making it look like we're doing it
all at the same time we like to look
busy right that's sort of an american
trade especially but what people mean by
what when they think what they think
they mean by multitasking is parallel
processing
yeah parallel processing or
it could be serial processing and you
know you you do one thing then you do
the next thing then you switch back to
the other thing back and forth and back
and forth and back and forth
the parallel processing might be more
like background tasking
and primary tasking where you know
somebody might be listening to this
podcast while folding their laundry
right
most people can do that
but can i have this conversation and
also be working on a presentation or
response to a client no i can't do it
and i could pretend to do it but i'd
actually be switching back and forth
and basically cognitively overloading my
brain and causing a lot of stress
studies have been done that show
it takes on average 23 minutes
to switch from one kind of cognitive
heavy task to another
because i like
if i tried to go from this conversation
to my work i'd need a little time to
figure out like where was i
what's this all about what are my goals
like
reviewing it for mistakes and all that
so we don't often give ourselves that
break that 23 minutes and it causes us
to get overwhelmed and stressed out and
burnt out to be honest
what's the route of multitasking is this
a perennial human problem the
philosophers of ancient athens
struggling with this as well
yeah i mean for sure it's definitely
been around for thousands of years part
of it is the
and that's an understatement but
it's part of is the design of the human
brain like we're supposed to take in
what's happening in our environment
be aware of the the dangers it's a wild
animal off the distance like i gotta
heighten my awareness and take care of
my family that's an ancient form of
multitasking right
another one is like sitting here but my
mind is wandering so can i bring it back
to the present moment through prayer
meditation those practices have been
around for a very long time
modern multitasking i think dates to
like the 1960s when computers were
introduced and we started to think about
how they
could multitask processes
switching from one application to
another so like the 1980s with windows
like you've everybody visualized it
at their desktop computer
oh i can go from excel to word
you know and my computer can run both
applications at the same time
well if humans designed those computer
programs
why can't we do the same thing why can't
we teach ourselves
to multitask
and then a lot of like employers started
you know kind of asking can you
multitask like we'd love to have you on
the team and we're going to throw all
this stuff at you
and then it became kind of glorified and
a lot of people brag about their ability
to multitask
but it's not actually good for us and
it's not something we're particularly
good at
why is it not good for us i understand
why it's not something that we're good
at
yeah so it causes like a physical and
mental strain on our bodies that we're
just not designed for
um
so i mentioned the 23-minute statistic a
few minutes ago so when we don't give
ourselves the time to switch from one
thing to another
we get stressed out we feel overwhelmed
we can't quite put our finger on it
um but we
you know there's a a real bottleneck
in our cognitive ability so like you'll
have people these days i hear a lot like
i don't enjoy my hobbies anymore
i just enjoy reading i used to enjoy
biking but you know
the fact that we always bring our phones
with us everywhere and a lot of people
do something like make a call scroll
through social media
it creates a multitasking bottleneck in
our brains so we can't like have that
feeling that we used to have of being in
the present moment
enjoying what we used to enjoy right now
right here and with the people we're
with
yeah it really does feel like we're not
immersed in experiences as much you know
i kind of i
critique myself all day about this i
mean a taxi journey good example i was
in a taxi journey to go for dinner last
night and i'm starting the taxi and i'm
driving through
south congress south austin's really
nice got downtown coming toward me i can
see the capital building sort of through
the dark
front windscreen next to the uber driver
and i was thinking this is really really
nice i'm just watching but i had to
consciously
think about not picking up my phone to
check if or maybe there's an email that
i can get to right now which is going to
make tomorrow a little bit easier
because i want i won't have that email
to do
um but even that even though i decided
not to task switch the
ambient sort of parallel processing
world or multiple uh multitasking world
even the thought of that took me out of
the present moment and being immersed in
it as well so you know there's like
there's gradations of how distracted you
can be when you're doing stuff but i
really really value that memory you know
thinking back about last night and
seeing the capitol building coming in
and it's cool and there aren't so many
skyscrapers in newcastle where i'm from
so it's a different sort of view for me
to see i really value that um
but it's so easy to avoid it did have
you thought i'm gonna guess that you
must have realized that boredom plays
a pretty big role here that a lot of the
time what people are doing with
multitasking is probably sedating
themselves from the boredom of one thing
with another thing
a hundred percent yeah so
you know what was going on in that that
car ride
you know is that we've trained ourselves
or we've been trained by technology and
our devices and despite the fast-paced
modern world we live in
that we never have to be bored
as soon as anybody gets bored these days
like our tendency is to reach for our
phone
as soon as we feel like oh i've got
whatever i'm doing right now down
i'm going to layer something else on so
it's it's just a habit and we have to go
easy on ourselves so like it's not our
fault that we're reaching for our phone
like there's billions of dollars and
lots of people on the other side of that
convincing us that that's what we should
do
um what i did the book the 12 mono tasks
that i wrote um
there's a chapter in there called
getting there and it's all about you
know how to pay attention to
the journey
whether that's your commute or your gut
you're in a new city or you're
um you know going on a trip and seeing
something new like
and just sit with the fact that you know
look out the window
pay attention to the things you've
you've never seen before or something
you know if you've taken this ride a
thousand times maybe you will notice
something new or maybe you'll just like
mono task your boredom
and be okay with that and and then not
reach for your phone so quickly in the
future
um there's also like this big impulse to
be like oh that's really cool i have to
take a picture
and it's like no you were there you it's
okay you know the experience was great
you remember it you had that feeling
and just the like the act of even
thinking about taking a picture
and layering on something else like can
really take us out of that moment
and that feeling of happiness and joy of
being where we are
what technology's done and not to lay
all of the problems of multitasking at
the feet of technology right like this
is as it seems a perennial desire for
humans to constantly rid themselves
aboard and by any means necessary
but it's
driven the price of removing boredom
essentially down to zero it's made it's
made it frictionless for us to be able
to get rid of that at any time so at the
slightest sign of discomfort what we do
is we then escape that we're waiting in
line somewhere we're on a journey
somewhere and for the people pretty much
everyone has some form of productive
work that they can do on their phone
even if that's just answering personal
emails or swiping stuff is unread so you
can always there's a kernel of truth in
it right that well this is
productive this is me being useful and
this journey's going to happen anyway
you know i'm going to to town i might as
well
use it for something useful um
what is it about monotasting that makes
it so hard then because when you think
about it
it sounds like it would take more effort
to do two things at once instead of one
and usually the human system's pretty
good at finding ways to be lazy so it's
kind of counterintuitive that monetary
is difficult
that's a great observation um
and i talked about that a little bit in
the book like if if it were easy
and obvious
it would be a very short book and and i
wouldn't have that much to say
um but it's actually it is really hard
and anybody that's tried to do one thing
at a time instead of multitasking
you know that so i think i also think
it's really simple that's one of the
greatest compliments i get it's like
this is so simple yet powerful like
it should be simple we should just be
able to decide like hey i'm doing five
things at once i'm gonna pick one i'm
gonna do with my full attention i'm
gonna move on to number two
the reality is that like multitasking
has become
very pleasurable
in some respects like you think about
media multitasking like you sit on the
couch with your phone you're texting
you're watching netflix you've got your
computer on you know maybe
occasionally popping in and checking an
email
um i think everybody can relate to that
like
you just relax and like you don't you're
not really getting much done you're not
paying full attention to anything
so i think that's where it becomes hard
paying full attention
instead of just paying partial attention
paying partial tension is easy
it just doesn't really
result in your best work or your most
efficiency
or really being present with the people
you care about that you're hanging out
with
um so i think it's pleasurable
i think it's habitual you know so like
everything in the world is just
glorified multitasking culture made you
think you can do it and you're gonna be
celebrated if you do it and here are
some you know celebrities and famous
people that do it on you know run their
fashion empire in between you know
playing tennis matches or whatever
um
so it's hard and i think
we
once you do the work and you you get
more accustomed to the feeling of what
it feels like to do one thing at a time
and you recognize like hey this isn't
something i've felt in a while
then that becomes more rewarding than
the multitasking and you start to
recognize like what you recognized in
the in the car like
hey i'm not paying full attention here
and i'm not enjoying this really cool
view
like what if i could do that and then
you you do it and then you like start to
make more of those moments in your life
more practice you do it the better you
become
i think that
very much the best work that we do is
when we're focused on a single thing and
beyond the
fact that we can't really multitask and
it's making our work
take longer and it's not as
psychologically fulfilling i think the
main
difference
that i've noticed with my friends that
are able to go sort of hard and deep
with one particular task is
the level of output in terms of the the
quality of the work the level of
creativity or ingenuity or
just
they are able to get to a higher level
by focusing on one thing
and the most important thing when you
think about what you're competing with
everybody else on you're not you're very
rarely in a job are you competing on the
volume of work that you can put out like
the best pitch that wins a new client
over is not the pitch with the most
words or the pitch that's been sent the
most times or the company that puts the
most ideas across it's usually the
company that has the single best idea
the person that gets the job isn't the
person with the longest cv it's the
person with the best cv with the highest
caliber of work and increasingly you see
this in in the world of podcasting or
youtube right the best youtubers and
podcasters on the planet they're not the
people that put out the most videos now
there might be some correlation between
consistency of content and um how
popular they are in the market but it's
not about that it's about the fact that
when you sit down and listen to whoever
your favorite podcaster is you know that
that's going to be a really really high
quality podcast so you don't care about
the fact that someone could live stream
their life 24 hours a day
but if it's not good it doesn't matter
and it's going to be beaten by the guy
that does one amazing hour of work per
week because he's fully focused on it so
i think that there needs to be a an
understanding a sort of a cultural
change so that people realize that you
genuinely aren't competing with other
people based on the volume of work that
you put out you're competing with it
based on the quality of the work that
you put out
yeah i think there's a lot of fear that
you know if i'm not creating this huge
volume of work and making it and telling
people about all the things i'm doing
and all the side hustles i have and all
you know the accomplishments like
that i'm somehow failing
but but you're absolutely right it's
it's about quality not quantity
almost all success in life
and and that comes from you know a
reference in the book cal newport and
deep work like
you have to like focus
do your when you get into the space of
like deep work
um and you learn how you do your best
deep work like
then you can do it you can do it more
often and you can be more successful and
you can take on a lot of things in life
like so i have a business
you know i'm a parent
written a couple books like it's a lot
of output
the only way i can do it is by doing one
thing at a time
i can't write a new book while i'm you
know talking to a customer on the phone
um
but i can do both in life and i don't
think that people should you know scale
back their expectations
of what they do
i think they should just do them one at
a time
and and i think there's a lot of fear
you know at the beginning when people
are so used to multitasking it's like i
i can't i can't slow down
you know then i won't be as productive
and what if i slow down and then like i
can't get back up to speed if i want to
you know so there's like any making any
habitual change like that like it takes
some courage to take the first step
give it a try and then realize oh i'm
actually going to get more done
i'm going to do better quality work
i'm going to be more connected
and i'm going to be better at like
everything in life to be a better
listener and that's not just going to
help me get the customer but
have a better relationship with a
partner
how did cancer change your view on this
stuff
yeah i mean cancer changed everything in
my life i mean i
i was a as a healthy person beforehand
very active
and then discovered i had three tumors
in my chest and had to go through pretty
intensive chemo about 100 hours a week
times six rounds
um so it's pretty grueling and what i
didn't know is that
that was just going to be the beginning
when i went through chemo everybody was
like oh chemo's so hard you're gonna be
sick you're weak lose weight not going
to want to eat
nobody really told me how long it was
going to take to recover from it and get
my energy back but it took like close to
four years
and and part of that was because i
pushed myself
too hard while i was going through
treatment to keep up with work try to
you know ride my bike
afterwards i like tried to keep up
appearances you know i was like the
really hard working creative optimistic
guy and i was like i feel like crap
and i didn't want people to know that
and i i was like i just get a good
night's sleep if i just like you know
take a day off if i just get this work
done maybe i'll feel better
and nothing worked
and it really just took a lot of time a
lot of like micro adjustments and so i
think it gave me this perspective that
like
you know what if i never get back to my
full strength
what if i have to slow down
what if i can't pretend like what if i
can't fake it till i make it
um
and so i made a lot of adjustments like
in my mindset in my like diet
in my daily routine
uh and the like where i gave my
attention because like that was
the one thing even though my body didn't
feel good
um
and even though i was exhausted
like i could give my attention to things
and choose where to apply that and
knowing that it was kind of precious and
limited
um
you know i decided to like really become
a keen observer about my attention my
focus
distractions in the world and
try to manage them a little bit better
in order to get more done
it's wild that 600 hours of chemotherapy
still wasn't enough to slow down your
desire to multitask
in the first place
yeah i mean i
you know i
yeah that's a good observation everybody
said like
slow down you know take care of yourself
you know you'll have time to
do you know whatever you're trying to do
on your laptop at the you know the
infusion center later
um but now i didn't listen because i
think i thought
like i did a lot of work
observing myself like on the side
effects and kind of
making those micro adjustments i talked
about like you know take aloe vera juice
for you know my stomach soreness and
whatever like i had a million tips and
tricks that i'd figured out and learned
from other cancer patients and and
practitioners um
but i still didn't want to slow down
yeah i mean that's and that i could like
i'd you know relate to other people in
this world whether they're going through
cancer or something else they're just
trying to get their startup off the
ground while working a full-time job
like
it's life everybody's going through
something and
you know there's a lesson to be learned
in all of it and i think we just always
have to you know learn from it and make
some adjustments to optimize
our happiness and our stress levels our
performance one of the things i've been
thinking about recently is um a
hourglass shaped or a a bottleneck shape
that a lot of journeys and sort of
passion projects that then perhaps
become businesses or you know
relationships that then get a little bit
more serious that they tend to follow so
this is complete bro signs so just bear
with me um at the beginning when you do
something it's usually new the novelty
motivates you
it's casual so there isn't that much
pressure this you know let's run this
for both
relationship and passion project that
becomes business right all of these
things are true for both of those
there's little pressure there's no some
cost fallacy there's no investment you
don't feel like it's part of your
identity people don't really care that
much about you doing it it's just a
thing that you're doing for fun over
time the
level of pressure and scrutiny that you
and other people place on you the amount
of investment that you have the amount
of work that you need to do the amount
of tasks and different areas that you
need to try and bring together in an
effective manner those start to ramp up
but you haven't got to this stage yet
where you've done it for so long that
you can either delegate control to
somebody else or kind of operationalize
some of the common challenges that you
face so that you become easier it
becomes easier to you so you go from the
wide neck right it's easy casual
less pressure to the narrowing in the
middle section which is when you've got
more pressure more workloads more tasks
to try and do a greater sense of
obligation to the people around you and
to the people that you work with but
then i do think that out the other side
of that you can actually get yourself to
a place especially in a business where
maybe you've recruited an assistant and
maybe there's a manager now and maybe
you've operationalized stuff and maybe
you've got a social media team in to
come and look after stuff and maybe
you've got somebody in that's going to
do finance and someone's going to do
marketing and you don't have to do your
own schedule anymore and it actually
it does follow a very odd sort of curve
shape
it goes from easy to difficult to easy
again however
what you realize is that the strategy
that got you from easy to difficult was
putting your nose against the grindstone
was going right i'm going to go as hard
as possible i'm going to do everything
i'm going to be across everything and
every business person that's listening
knows how difficult it is to let go of
control to delegate and to relinquish
the tasks that you usually do to new
people because you know that they're
going to get it wrong at least a little
bit more than you do right now and
letting go is it makes you terrified so
a lot of the time you don't ever allow
yourself to get out the other side of
that hourglass bottleneck
to find the easy stuff that's on the
other side in a relationship as well you
know you're going to have
most disagreements in relationships are
going to center around probably
five things you know it's going to be
consistent thing that happens you
choosing to do one thing instead of
another you choosing to not do this
thing instead of that those are the
disagreements that are fundamentally
going to happen so operationalize those
as well but if you don't allow yourself
to be able to come up with the solutions
to delegate control in a business or to
try and i guess break down those
challenges in relationships you just
stay in that middle section so yeah
that's my that's my cod psychology uh
solution for you
yeah no i love it and i can totally
relate to that
um you know so i've had my business
juniper books for 21 years now
and not to disappoint any you know
entrepreneurs people starting up
companies like it it never really
gets
it gets easier and then it gets harder i
mean i don't know if it's one hour glass
shape or it's like multiple yeah yeah
yeah because i'm going through a lot of
that right now i'm you know especially
as i'm trying to like work more on
promoting mono tasking and sharing the
message with the world like i'm trying
to delegate more and more i have 20
employees
every one of those people does something
now that i used to do for myself
so i've got like 20x you know my
capability or whatever which is awesome
like that's where you want to get to but
then like you know i gotta get another
like five percent off my plate gotta
find the right person gotta train them
um you know but once i get them up to
speed like that i'm gonna help like
manage them to build their team so
yeah so not to disappoint anybody out
there that they're gonna be on easy
street at some point um but yeah you
have to work on it and you figure out a
lot of things along the way um and i do
think it's true
um you know with relationships and our
personal life and
our hobbies you know it's like
yeah you can learn how to
do a new sport
and then you can get better at it you
know and then you have your setbacks and
then you you know work on it again
and
it's life and i think we should go we
should be realistic
about the learning process
and the ups and downs that we're going
to encounter
a lot of people like look at a lot of
like the stories you read in the press
you know like oh so so you know raised a
billion dollars sold their company
whatever like whilst being an endurance
racer and building a family and doing
all of this yeah i mean those are the
stories that are great for the press to
tell
it's not you know what for every one of
those there's you know 10 000 other
people
um
and a lot of them like you'll never hear
about and they figure it out and they're
running their businesses day to day and
they have a great life and like that's
i think what most of us should aspire to
um
yeah
there's a
uh
quote that i saw the other day that says
you want everybody to know your name and
nobody to know your face
and i think that that kind of
just highlights the people that have
that huge outlier success like that
outliers by definition as opposed to the
people that just iterate steady away on
something that works so given the fact
that you have your
book company plus you're an author
perhaps unsurprisingly you said that one
of the most important mono tasks was to
read so what's the advantage of reading
especially given the fact that a lot of
people that i know
talk about reading but what they mean is
listening to books on audible so their
consumption of books is actually the
same way as you would do a podcast
because maybe they they struggle to sit
down
and focus on a book for a long period of
time
so i've thought a lot about reading
because i've been in the book business
for so long and i've thought about like
you know how do we what what benefit
does it provide us besides just like
entertainment or information so we can
get information from an audiobook or
podcast
um
and you know what i've what i came to
the conclusion about is that like
reading really helps us build our focus
so that and then we can apply that focus
to other parts of our life and when i
looked around at successful people like
bill gates and oprah winfrey and warren
buffett like they're big readers
some of the busiest people in the world
are some of the biggest readers
like how do they have time for that why
do they bother like couldn't they just
be going and like starting more
companies and making more money and what
i saw is that there's a correlation
between
you know the habits of successful people
their ability to pay attention and then
their ability to be successful in life
and so i think what reading does for us
and i do think it's great like however
you get your books and information
is great that's better than not reading
so
but i do think there's something special
about the printed page
when you bring your when you hold a book
in your hands it like takes up space and
has like a weight to it
you're like you're in one place
um
your attention looking at the page is in
one place too and it goes you know down
one page and then up to the next one
and people like create these
spatial maps in their minds of like
where they read something where they
were
they may not be aware of this
where certain things happen in the book
you have that feeling like how far into
it am i my you know i'm about halfway
through am i near the end oh shoot like
i don't want the story to end like real
readers can relate to that
and i think all that's good for us and i
think it's a feature not a flaw that we
can't multitask while we're reading
it's one of like the true mono tasks
that i you know came up with this idea
about monotasking for
it's like you can only read a book while
you're reading a book
on paper
audiobooks and kindles and stuff like
you can multitask
um and i think that's a good thing and i
think if we read for a little bit every
day like it strengthens our what i call
our mono-tasking muscles and our ability
to pay attention and then we can apply
that to our work to our relationships to
our hobbies
you know what it's like to read a
paragraph and then to realize that
you've been distracted and someone could
hold a gun to your head and say tell me
what happened in that last paragraph
you're like dude i'm i'm sorry and your
eyes have tracked it
all the way and that's so fascinating
the way that our focus works the way
that we can be doing something kind of
passively and yet our mind can be
completely somewhere else and then we
kind of
you catch yourself having not been where
you were
which is such a bizarre sentence to say
i mean that's my that's multitasking
right so yeah you're pretending to read
the book you're monotone you're thinking
and your brain is somewhere else
so that's multitasking there's nothing
wrong with it i mean yeah you're not you
have to go back and reread that
paragraph
that's fine that happens to everybody
even like the strongest most focused
people in the world
but um you know i think just having that
awareness that like that's
essentially what's happening you know
with everything else we're doing in life
you know like if i was having this
conversation
and thinking about lunch or something
like it's the same thing it's not like
terrible for us you know i may not
you know be as
speaking as clearly as i struggle to
find my words i'm like
like maybe i am thinking about lunch but
um
you know i think it's just like having
that awareness going easier on ourselves
and then saying like what if i did give
my full attention to what i'm doing
right now either the book this
conversation
the walk that i might go on after this
like
it's different you know and and i think
it's not only good for what we do in the
moment
but it like really strengthens our
monotastic muscles that have atrophied
thanks to technology and a lot of other
stuff
and then we can we can apply them you
know and then be more successful and
have more fun
what would you advise to people who
perhaps are the audiobook connoisseur
that i've just mentioned but are
struggling to sit down they sit down to
read a book and they can't they can
barely even get through half a page
before they want to fidget and move
around and then leave it
yeah i mean i'd say you know start where
you are and it's it's not one thing or
the other so i listen to audio books
um but i also read a lot of books
i've started so i think like any amount
that you could spend reading on paper
daily is good for you
start with five minutes in the book i
talk about 20 minutes as being like an
optimal amount
and start with something easy reread a
book you love in childhood i don't care
if it's dr seuss like start with
something on paper um i love to reread
like jd salinger and kurt vonnegut i've
got a bunch of those books on my shelf
behind me like they're pretty
fast you know going easy reads
um don't start with one piece right like
don't or a medical journal or something
like that red rising i'm telling you if
you need a book to get into get pierce
brown
red rising is the one
yep we we make it like a special edition
set of red rosin in a way books yeah and
it's yeah it's one of our most popular
offerings
he's he's absolutely crushed it so i put
uh yeah i'm gonna go in a complete segue
i put a tweet out the other day saying i
was struggling to find something as good
as uh pierce brown's red rising or
patrick roth versus is the name of the
wind
and then whatever the the way of kings
or i think the second one was um
and i got a ton of interesting responses
but i think one of the things that you
one of the things that i found that's
interesting there's two types of fiction
books that i've been really enjoying
recently one of them are unbelievably
fast-paced so something like red rising
is just like
unrelenting something happens and then
everybody's dead and then everybody's
not dead and then there's a spaceship
and then you know someone takes over a
planet but then if you look at rothfuss
and the way that he writes
it's so slow it's it's genuinely
pedestrian
you know you get to know
kvoth the guy who is the main
protagonist in the books you get to know
his daily routine you get to know his
walk to work like his walk to when he
goes to go and play his loot the local
um pub that he plays in
you and you know the color of his room
you know the shape of his room and it's
so slow and pedestrian but i really
really enjoyed that and i wondered i it
kind of makes me think about the
multitasking versus the monetary
appearing kind of within a narrative
that you've got one book and i felt you
know i really really enjoyed red rising
and pierce is going to come on the show
once he's finished the next one which
i'm excited about but
there was an extra level of
it was like uh like taking a bath or
something just real luxuriating in the
slowness of the narrative when you read
the name of the wind and um it's so good
it's fantastic
i mean at any given time i've got like
five different books on my nightstand i
i and i just like depending on the mood
i'm in like some days you've had a
really stressful day and like
you can't take the like really deep
literary fiction like and you want that
page turner or you might just want like
a biography and like read a paragraph
before you fall asleep you know so i
think people should
don't feel like if you read one thing
and it doesn't work for you that like oh
i can't read like find the thing that
works for you read like a magazine you
know pick up in the airport and just you
know that might be what you're feeling
that day
i think the other thing is a good tip
that i share
is if you love audiobooks
and you loved a particular book pick up
the print copy
like you'll have that familiarity with
it it'll be in a relatively easy read
you'll still get something new out of it
um and it's a good place to start
reading on paper
one of the things i know that we're
talking about print books here but if
you've got a kindle um like a paperwhite
or whatever there's a an extension for
google chrome called center kindle
and you press a button
and the web page that you're looking at
let's say it's a blog post or whatever
it'll appear on your kindle fully
optimized highlightable incomplete
kindle font where you can
adjust everything in the margins and all
that stuff and it just means that it
turns your kindle into an e-reader for
the stuff that you see on the internet
so now as i'm going around and people
send me articles or whatever during the
day or i've got a summary of
thatcherwines the twelve monotasks book
or something i think why i can press
this one button and then at some point
when i decide to open it up it's all
going to be sat there in my library so
that for me is a much better way to read
articles as well rather than reading it
on medium on my phone or on sub stack on
my laptop or something like that you
know you receive a sub stack from
someone press the title on the top you
go to the web page press the center
kindle there you go there's scott
alexander's new blog post sat
like a book at in and you know it's
going to take you maybe 15 minutes so
that's your read the next morning
sometimes if you're finding it difficult
to get into books perhaps articles via
e-reader might be a good place to look
at as well
yeah no it's an interesting concept and
i think you know i wonder if that like
creates a mindset shift for you that
you're not just like mindlessly surfing
the web
and it's purposeful yeah right so it's
it's like you're reading it's your
information consumption um it's your
checking in on you know the authors
whereas
you know so much of the algorithm-driven
stuff that we're fed
you know is just kind of mindless and
it's so hard to stop wait it's the
environment that you're in right you
know you're sad
the guys rob henderson is able to read
full journal articles my buddy rob is
able to read full journal articles on
his phone
dude that is
super human
being able to do that i can't believe
that someone could read you know a very
dry extended
piece of work on the phone because for
me that environment just isn't conducive
to deep focus and you know a laptop's
only a little bit better than that but
again what's the environment that you're
in yeah you've got kindle in hand
there's no swiping there's no bings
there's no bombs and then a
paper book is one step further from that
well i mean everything can be monotonic
so like all those little tips and tricks
like you know instead of
being in this like information overload
i'm on a web browser i've got these
notifications coming in just being like
i'm going to mono task this journal
article or this
you know whatever medium piece or the
story like you know and give it your
full focus and and you know people have
been asking me like can you monetize
social media
and you know i think you can like it's
super distracting but when i do it i
basically go in with a purpose
i'm creating something i'm either
applying the creating mono task that's
in my my book and just thinking of it as
a creative act that i'm putting up a
post
um or i think of it as playing like i'm
just having fun you know this is like
you know a joke it's a whimsy whimsical
thing i'm doing like i just want to
connect with the world through my humor
um
and and if i'm looking at other people's
stuff like i'm pretty much just like
going to figure out what my friends are
doing or what this person said and then
i'm getting out of there
and it's hard i mean everything is
designed so that you
don't do that so you stay and an hour
later you're like what am i doing
where'd the time go
um but i think you know you can make
that decision kind of like what you're
talking about it's like i'm gonna
reframe it
and i'm gonna you know use my time
wisely to get what works for me
reframing the experience and what you
tell yourself about it as well you know
if you do get distracted this is
something that i struggle with
if i spend
you know an hour accidentally falling
down some youtube rabbit hole and before
i know it that's an hour of my day gone
and i think are you idiot
you had so much stuff to do and look
you've just spent the last hour learning
about some crypto nft scam that jake
paul's going to get sued for or
something like nothing that you're never
ever going to use uh so
i've been working a lot on trying to
reframe the stories that i tell myself
about my multitasking and monetizing did
you come across information foraging and
the theory of information foraging
during your research
um i mean i i don't think i'm
specifically familiar with that term but
i can imagine what it is yeah so the
it was sam harris had a neuroscientist
on that was talking about parallel
processing and multitasking and he said
that um in the same way that squirrels
are nut foragers uh humans are
information foragers and for pretty much
all of our history
the people that had the most information
were the ones that had the biggest
advantage and then at some point within
the last 100 years of our evolution it
switched from the person that has the
most information to the person that's
able to discern the information the best
and actually stay focused on the most
relevant information so he uses this
example there's a
mathematical formula that you can use
to look at how many nuts are left in a
tree
and how far away the next tree is
to work out
the likelihood of a squirrel leaving
that tree to go to the next one because
there's a cost that you need to pay to
leave the tree and go to the next tree
but if the number of nuts that are in
this tree start to diminish so much that
the effort is worth changing so he
applied that to humans in information
foraging and he said that one of the
problems we have with
social media and technology is that the
friction from going from tree to tree
has essentially dropped to zero and this
is one of those things where a lot of
the time you'll read you'll see an
article that looks interesting on
twitter click on it read the title read
the subheading click off it go back to
twitter to find something else like
you've just selected an article that you
thought to yourself would be interesting
to read and you managed to get through
the first paragraph and then really
enough like i'll jump to another tree um
so yeah i think
being aware of that being conscious and
mindful of that compulsion to go
somewhere else is is pretty important
and also what you were talking about
earlier on the fact that when you're
having a conversation with somebody like
this
not being distracted not trying to think
about other things i think that the
prescription for people to try and have
a a private podcast with one of their
friends for you know half an hour or an
hour per week talking about something in
a rigorous focused way without
distractions
it's so therapeutic and it makes you
such a better conversationalist because
you have the skill to be able to care
about what the other person says and you
talk about this as well right that
listening is actually a skill that
people can develop and that they can
monetize
yeah there's a whole chapter on
listening in the book and one of my tips
um i don't know if it's in the book or
not um to be honest but is listen as if
you're recording a podcast
you know listen like
it's uncomfortable
that you're paying so much attention the
other person's like hey what's going on
here like normally you're looking at
your phone
what happened um
you know that's that's what we should do
we have to do it in every single
conversation we should have the skills
to do it
nothing in our adult lives and maybe
nothing in our you know childhood either
these days like
teaches us how to do that and rewards us
for doing that i mean yeah you might
have friends that are like i want to
hang out with that guy he's he listens
um
but you know but and you're kind of sort
of rewarded like
because i think listening is important
to sales and customer service and the
success of businesses like how well you
listen to your customers and change your
products and your marketing strategy
but nobody talks about it really as
listening
and so we don't like really measure it
we don't really tell people to develop
that skill necessarily
it's super important especially in
relationships
um you know as a parent
like
there's so much there's some things that
are said a lot of things that aren't
said and if you're multitasking you're
not going to hear either
you might hear what's said you're
definitely not going to hear what's not
said
in between the lines or the words or
whatever
if you're just thinking looking at your
phone or thinking about something else
um
so i think it's super rewarding i think
we should do more of it
what about walking
so yeah so there's a chapter i'm walking
in the book and and that kind of grew
out of this idea that like
you know we we tend to combine
our walks with other stuff whether it's
like i'm walking for exercise or i'm
walking i'm gonna make a phone call
or i'm gonna take pictures
like what if we just went for a walk
what if we just like
you know opened our eyes like looked up
instead of down on our phones
and you know saw new things i'm looking
out the window here it's like gorgeous
colorado setting super bright i look
super pale
that's a result um
but i should probably get out and get
some sunshine
uh but you know
you see things you've never seen before
hear sounds you've never heard before
like if you're walking around city you
might smell some things you've never
smelled before and that's okay hopefully
it's like a bakery or something
um
but like it makes us alive to you know
absorb all this cool stuff in the world
and be grateful for it to be honest
and and practice that ability like not
to reach for our phone
um
and just be a little bit bored maybe i
don't think walking's boring personally
but some people might think it is and
they might be like i better go for a run
um but i think just like slowing down
enjoying the walk is very therapeutic
yeah i am
morning walk is the most important thing
that i do as a part of my day if i if i
get that in even if it's just five
minutes the rest of the day is usually
like noticeably better as opposed to the
days when i've woken up too late or i've
got too much to do and i can't fit it in
even with that though i find myself
i've been tempted to do uh
diction uh pronunciation exercises while
i walk or i'm gonna do i'm gonna spend
the entire walk thinking of all
different things that i'm grateful for
so set myself a challenge and that is
still i'm finding a way to i've left my
phone don't take my phone out on a
morning i've still managed to find a way
to multitask
a walk which is specifically there to be
this lovely
oasis of calm first thing in the morning
and then there's me doing sinful caesar
sipped his snifter seized his knees and
sneezed first thing in the morning as
i'm walking around scaring all of the
dogs and cats yeah
i mean one you know i mentioned the the
23-minute statistic earlier about like
switching from one task to another and
how long it takes to prepare you know to
get into the next task
so
one way i think about walks sometimes is
like if you're going to lose that 23
minutes
anyway you're going to be sitting at
your desk you'll be like okay what do i
have to do how do i you know get into
the
mind space for that
like maybe you should just go for a walk
and and use that as your reset time
23 minutes it's like you're gonna lose
it
get up do something clear your head and
it's it's actually
i don't think it's that you should never
multitask on the walks you can use them
purposefully like what you're doing
because that you could argue like
the thing that you're doing in the
foreground is absolutely yes your
exercise and the background is just
you're walking
um so i think it's good to combine kind
of like your reading it's like combine
different types of walks
have one where you're like doing nothing
but paying attention to like the ground
underneath your feet
another one maybe you decide like i'm
gonna like think of a new idea for this
project
um
and then other ones like you'll you'll
go out
you know just planning to clear your
head and then you like the most creative
idea will pop into your mind
um because you decided to do nothing
and if you had decided to do something
like it wouldn't have showed up
and i think that's a really cool
experience especially for creatives and
entrepreneurs yeah that highlights the
difference between walking and reading
right that with reading it's always a
front brain task you can't do something
else whilst you read whereas with
walking it's automated same thing goes
for driving you've got a part in there
about getting there right commutes and
journeys and trips and stuff
most people that are competent drivers
are able to do something else mentally
whilst they're navigating traffic with
their hands and feet
so that means that there are different
ways i think to probably look at
monotasting and multitasking i would
probably
classify
being on a zoom call whilst writing an
email as a different sort of multitask
to
being in a car whilst thinking about
something for work or being on a walk
whilst listening to a podcast if there's
something that you can outsource to
system two
meanwhile system one is sorry to system
one meanwhile system two is actually
active doing something else i think
that's quite different
yeah and i think we
like just having the self awareness to
think about those things as being
different and not lumping them all
together like
oh i have to multitask all the time
otherwise i'll never get anything done
or i can't mono task or
or i can only mono task like there are
different subtleties within it like you
were just talking about
there's the background tasking and
primary task
driving making a phone call laundry
podcast
and then there's like the cognitive
heavy tasks
and if you can learn
you know what you can and you can't do
then you can make better decisions about
what stresses you out what makes you
productive
what makes you happy what makes you
connected
you can decide like i i better not even
take my phone out while i'm out on a
date because i know that like my brain
is going to look at it and i'm going to
be distracted and she's not going to
want to go out again
so i think it can be really helpful in
all situations what about learning and
uh teaching
so
yeah so those are two chapters in the
book and then to a certain extent
they're you know two sides of the same
thing um
but you know i definitely believe in
you know learning continuous learning
throughout our lives i like
have a lot of hobbies and i'm
trying to find more time to add
additional ones learn new instruments
and take up new sports and all that and
i think having like a
beginner's mind um if you're familiar
with that like a buddhist term about
like
i'm not a know at all about anything
even stuff i've been doing for 21 years
you know there's always something to
learn
and opening yourself up to the
possibility
and then monetizing the learning
right so saying like i'm learning right
now like i'm learning how
to you know talk about mono tasking
better i'm learning about you know how
to manage my time whatever
and then
you know make those self observations
that we've talked about throughout the
podcast like
and then apply the lessons don't feel
like you have to do what everybody else
does don't feel like you have to learn
how they learn
um
or do what they do find what works for
you
and the other side of his teaching like
the teaching chapter
people shouldn't skip it because they're
like i'm not a professional teacher i
don't you know stand in front of a
classroom teach people we're all
teachers all the time
you know i might teach my kids something
just by them seeing me do it or a
complete stranger might see how i like
talk to the waiter in a restaurant
be like oh that's you know i was very
respectful and empathetic and
kind and then learn from it um
so but but on the other hand like if you
really like somebody ask you can you
teach me how to play that song on guitar
you know then i really have to think
about huh i like how do i do it
how do i teach it
and it like creates this whole like next
level mono tasking that like brings your
focus
to what you know
how can you transmit it to somebody else
how are they receiving it as a learner
should i make some adjustments
um and you can basically you know you
can develop mastery of things that you
weren't didn't know you're an expert in
necessarily but somebody else thought
you could teach it
or maybe your own career like you can
take it to the next level
just by thinking about how would i teach
this to other people so it's pretty cool
what are the most common
resistances that people encounter when
they're trying to implement monetary
more into their lives
um you know some people say it's it's um
it's a luxury like it's it's a privilege
like i don't have time i have bills to
pay
i you know have too much to do you know
maybe when i'm retired i'll be able to
do that you know
and i think that um you know we get in
our own way i think
there's a present moment
every moment
right here right now like with the
people you're with doing the thing
you're doing
wherever you are
and if you recognize like i could either
do two or five things in this moment or
i could do one
and if you do one like
it's in the present moment you're not
you know distracting yourself and
diluting yourself and your capabilities
so i think you know you give it a try
and and see if it works for you
um so i think there's just like a little
bit of that fear um of people getting
their own way that's one of the big ones
losing memories and not being able to
recall the things that you've done
is one of the biggest advantages that i
can see
of this
i don't know how it works i'd love to
speak to an europe a neuroscientist and
and find out why it is that when you try
and have two things in your mind at once
you can barely remember either of them
it's not like you remember 50 of a trip
if you spent the entire trip obsessing
about something for work you just don't
remember any of the trip and you
probably can't remember what you were
obsessing about to do with work either
and
yeah especially because i'm out here in
austin and i'm meeting new people and
going to new places and stuff and i'm
really really conscious like i want to
remember this it's cool it's the first
time that i've been in another country
for an extended period of time i want to
spend i want to be able to look back and
really enjoy the memories that i've
created and yet it's antithetical to the
way that i spent most of the last 10 or
15 years of my life trying to run a
business trying to be on whatsapp whilst
taking calls whilst thinking about two
or three or four other things all at the
same time
so
yeah i think
the quality of life change that you're
going to have from monetary would
probably be worth it on its own but then
when you think about the increase in the
quality of your output that you're going
to have the down regulation in terms of
stress all that stuff
yeah man i mean it's
it it really is i think the perennial
sort of modern person problem
yeah modern but yet an ancient problem
just you know a little bit more
information weaponized with technology
yeah yeah but i was at an event recently
and um
you know just having a side conversation
with somebody and i introduced myself
and said hi my name is thatcher he got
oh i want to remember that and he got
out notebook and he wrote down my name
and i was like come on my name's like
memorable right it's not like john or
something
um
but i was like that's a great hack you
know tip that he figured out for himself
like
yes he brings himself into the present
moment this person's name is thatcher i
don't know if he made a note about what
i looked like or something
it's monotony like everybody else is
like oh hey yeah
um and then you forget what their name
is maybe because you were thinking about
something else maybe you're just bad
with names it doesn't really matter but
like if you can find what works for you
whether it's to record those memories um
or something else and let's just like
fully pay attention everything's better
i would say i i realized this as well
that
i had an aversion to taking photos for a
while
uh and one of the reasons for that was
i'd confused taking photos for posting
on social media you know it's super
cringe if you're out at dinner and
somebody decides to try and take a
million photos of the food because you
know that they're not taking the photo
of the food because they want to
remember the food they're doing it
because they want to flex on whatever
social network about whatever food
they're eating or whatever restaurant it
is
and that had sort of made me feel a bit
ick about
recording the stuff that i did but then
yusef one of my good buddies he's an
absolute fiend with it and i really i
very much appreciate and i'm envious of
how many photos he has that capture the
things that he's done
and i think that there's maybe a place
it's certainly something that i needed
to stress test myself on the fact that
because i didn't like the idea of taking
a photo for someone else didn't mean
that i shouldn't be taking a photo just
for me and the difference between your
man that's written it down in a notepad
and said hey thatcher why don't we take
a photo together and just snapped a a
photo i do think that there's probably a
way that you can be quite
present and quite monetised whilst
taking a photo however if it's
performative and it's then being done
for someone else i think that that's
where i draw the line
i think that's a great distinction yeah
i mean i think
if you're doing it for yourself because
like this is how you're fully present
if you're taking a picture of your food
because you're like
you know i'm gonna enjoy it more i'm
gonna taste the flavors i'm gonna write
about you know i want to remember like
where on the plate this was positioned
before i ate it or something and then
i'm gonna tell the story of it later but
but i think that like
if you're if you're multitasking it like
if you're not actually if you're just
thinking about what it looks like while
you're doing anything it's live concert
or food or
trip you're on or something like if
you're always thinking like oh this
would look so cool to people who aren't
here
it's
yeah it's one thing and then if it's
like this will heighten my enjoyment of
being in the present moment and my
senses and you know my connection to
these people
um then it's a different thing and i
think we can
you know social media is not great about
drawing that distinction
um or teaching us anything really um
but you know we can
you could think about it in multitasking
and multitasking terms is it just wait
as a way to frame it am i monotasking
am i doing two things but it's still the
same mono task
of eating of walking of traveling
or am i doing two things and they're
really multitasking because i'm here but
i'm thinking about that social media
post that i'm going to create later
that's your wine ladies and gentlemen if
you want to check out the book it will
be linked in the show notes below the 12
mono tasks and if people want to find
out more about you where should they go
so i have a website um i have two
websites maybe three uh thatcherwine.com
monotasking.tips
and juniperbooks.com if you want to
check out red rising and some of the
other things we talked about awesome i
appreciate you cheers man thanks chris
pleasure what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you